the sad truth here is that many of us
who are fighting to free Palestine are
fighting for all people's freedom
including for Jewish Liberation I take
you to the televised mental institution
known as MSNBC where Joy Reed and we
have not played a clip of Joy Reed in
quite some time I'm gonna unbutton my
jacket for this Joy Reed so I'm ready to
when I when we come back um to give it
my full emotion here is Joy Reed
interviewing a ruter professor so she
must be very learned ruter professor
um about how Elon Musk is a Jew hater
and so when we see Elon Musk there and
you're scratching your head and saying
but wait a minute I thought that he was
actually you know has said very
anti-semitic things it's precisely
because these are not the same thing you
can support Israel and hate Jewish
people and that's and that's the the sad
truth here is that many of us who are
fighting to free Palestine are fighting
for all people's freedom including for
Jewish
Liberation that woman's fighting for
Jewish Liberation by supporting
Palestine you can hate Jewish people but
support Israel these people does
somebody can we I want to send one of
you guys maybe we'll put you guys in a
costume we're going to send you over to
them as NBC headquarters and I want you
to bring a uh I want you to just look
around and I want you to see right
before you know they get in the green
room they put their makeup on does
someone hit them with a frying pan right
before they get on camera like whack
them with a cast iron frying pan
and thus cause the brain damage that is
on that Network Elon Musk is not an
anti-semite if it wasn't for Elon Musk
opening up Twitter we would not have
seen the the hundreds of videos the
horrific videos that people in Oakland
pretend do not exist and the reason they
don't think they exist is because
they're being censored on other uh
social media Outlets but if if you're
still a little confused at this point as
to whether Elon Musk who just went to
Israel went to the kabut that were
burned down saw the video the 47 minut
minutes a video including a woman who
was pregnant who they literally sliced
her stomach open and took the fetus out
and let her die out in front of her that
is literal he saw it for himself here is
Elon uh talking about Hamas and what
they did it was jarring to see the scene
of the massacre or one of the scenes of
the massacr um as well as to see the
short film
afterwards uh that uh showed a you know
more of of innocent people getting
killed I was troubling in that movie
especially to see the joy experienced by
the people that were killing innocent
civilians including kids and you know
babies and defenseless people
essentially
so
um you know it's it's one thing if
obviously if civilians die accidentally
um but if it's another thing to Revel in
the joy of killing civilians that's not
you know that's frankly that's evil yeah
that is evil and that's the guy they're
telling you is the number one
anti-semite that's the one that for the
last how many how many shows have I done
about Elon Musk in the last year plus
since he got Twitter which was right
around what was it about October last
year so he's had it for about 14 months
something like that how many episodes
have we done on this of the mainstream
media absolutely lying about him because
he's competition now how many shows have
we done about Joe Rogan because he's
competition now nobody in their right
mind thinks that Elon Musk is an
anti-semite you want to find some
anti-semites go to the New York Times
you want to find some anti-semites turn
on MSNBC say hi to Andrea
Mitchell